PIPE DOWN ONES BIDEN TOOK THE
MICROPHONE.
BRET?
SPAM PETER DOOCY,
THANKS.
THE DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE HAS DECLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS TODAY REVEALING FORMER
CIA DIRECTOR JOHN BRENNAN BRIEF
THEN PRESIDENT OBAMA ON
HILLARY CLINTON’S PURPORTED PLAN
TO SMEAR THEN CANDIDATE TRUMP IN
2016, ADDING TO WHAT THE
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE DIRECTOR
HAS ALREADY DECLASSIFIED ON THIS
ISSUE.
AND RAISING MORE QUESTIONS
TONIGHT ABOUT HOW MUCH MORE OF
THIS WILL COME OUT BEFORE
ELECTION DAY.
SENIOR POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT
MIKE EMANUEL IS FOLLOWING THE
STORY TONIGHT IN WASHINGTON.
GOOD EVENING.
>> THESE ARE HANDWRITTEN NOTES
FROM FORMER CIA DIRECTOR
JOHN BRENNAN WRITTEN FROM A
SOURCE FAMILIAR AFTER BRENNAN
BRIEFED PRESIDENT OBAMA.
AT ONE POINT HE WRITES "APPROVED
BY HILLARY CLINTON, A PROPOSAL
FROM ONE OF HER FOREIGN POLICY
ADVISORS TO VILIFY DONALD TRUMP
BY STIRRING UP A SCANDAL,
CLAIMING INTERFERENCE BY THE
RUSSIAN SECURITY SERVICE."
THE NOTES SAY ON 28TH OF JULY
COME IN THE MARGIN RIGHTS "
"POTUS" BUT THAT IS REDACTED.
THEN ANY COLLABORATION BETWEEN
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIA.
THE REMAINDER OF THE NOTES ARE
REDACTED, EXCEPT IN THE MARGINS
WHERE IT SAYS "JAY-Z, DENNIS,
AND
SUSAN."
THAT COULD BE REFERRING TO
JAMES COMEY, FORMER NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR SUSAN RICE.
THE CIA SENT A MEMO TO FORMER
FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY AND
PETER STRZOK, WRITING A BOOK
WITH THE FOLLOWING INFORMATION
IS PROROVIDED FOR THE EXCLUSIVE
USE OF YOUR BUREAU FOR
BACKGROUND INVESTIGATIVE ACTION
OR LEAD PURPOSES AS
APPROPRIATE."
ONE EXAMPLE OF THE CIA INCLUDES,
"IN EXCHANGE REDACTED DISCUSSING
U.S. PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN
CANDIDATE HILLARY CLINTON’S PLAN
CONCERNING YOU U.S. CANDIDATE
DONALD TRUMP AND RUSSIAN
ELECTION AS A MEANS OF
DISTRACTING HER USE OF A PRIVATE
EMAIL SERVER."
A HEARING BEFORE THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE LAST WEEK,
JAMES COMEY WAS PRESSED WITH
WHAT HE DID WITH INFORMATION
PROVIDED BY BY THE CIA.
>> DID YOU OPEN AN
INVESTIGATION?
>> I DON’T KNOW WHAT, AS I SAID,
THAT DOES NOT RING ANY BELLS
WITH ME WHEN I READ THAT.
>> DID YOU NOT RECEIVE ANY
INVESTIGATIVE REFERRAL OF THIS
NATURE?
>> I DON’T REMEMBER IT.
I DON’T REMEMBER SEEING ANYTHING
THAT IS DESCRIBED IN THAT